We're supposed to smell the roses, notice the sunsets, live life to the fullest. But this is not always possible. In fact, it's not always advisable.
我们理应去闻闻玫瑰花香，看看落日余晖，尽情享受生活。但这并非总是可能的。事实上，这也并非总是明智的。
Robert says that he began the part of his life when he felt the most alive a few years ago, when he was on a trip to Ireland. He attended a horse jumping competition in a big stadium.
罗伯特说，他感到人生最鲜活的阶段始于几年前的一次爱尔兰之旅。当时他去参加了一个大型体育场举办的马术跳跃比赛。
It was a great international competition. And they had Ireland, of course, was there. And Britain and France and Italy and Germany, and Australia, I think, was there.
那是一场伟大的国际赛事。当然，爱尔兰队参赛了。还有英国、法国、意大利、德国，我想澳大利亚也参加了。
Well, I was watching that. And I was thinking, "Well, God, what do you want me to do with my life?" And so I was at the International Jumping Derby, and I noticed that the United States wasn't there. And so I took this as a message from above that I should do something to improve the riding program in the United States.
那时我正在观看比赛，心想：“天哪，你究竟想让我的人生去做什么呢？”当时我身处国际跳跃德比大赛现场，我注意到美国队并没有参赛。于是，我将此视为上天的旨意，认为我应该做点什么来改善美国的马术项目。
I felt that I was struck by a bolt of lightning of sorts, a kind of a psychic bolt of lightning. I said, "This is what God wants me to do." And so that was my mission, was to improve the riding program of the United States.
我感觉自己被某种闪电击中了，一种精神上的闪电。我说：“这就是上帝要我做的事。”因此，改善美国马术项目成了我的使命。
At that time, Robert had already suffered from a few bouts of psychosis and delusion. One time, he thought a light bulb in his closet was giving him special messages from God. Another time, he believed he was an angel with special powers, sent to help mankind. But saving the US equestrian team, there was something so earthly about that, so modest.
那时候，罗伯特已经经历过几次精神病和妄想症的发作。有一次，他认为衣橱里的灯泡在向他传递上帝的特殊信息。另一次，他坚信自己是派遣来拯救人类的拥有特殊力量的天使。但拯救美国马术队这件事，却显得如此世俗，如此谦卑。
Robert loved horses, loved to ride. And one thing led to another. And before long, he was the nation's number one salesman of US equestrian team t-shirts and caps and paraphernalia.
罗伯特热爱马匹，热爱骑行。事情一件接着一件地发展。没过多久，他就成了美国马术队的T恤、帽子和相关装备的全国头号推销员。
He would get the stuff from a wholesaler, go to horse shows, sell it to horsey enthusiasts, trying to drum up support for the cause, all without any official sanction or authorization of the US equestrian team. It was exciting. He traveled all over the country, met people, talked about his mission. At one point, he became convinced that the way to save the US equestrian team would be to involve the US military.
他会从批发商那里进货，去马展上把东西卖给马术爱好者，试图为这项事业争取支持，而这一切都没有得到美国马术队的正式许可或授权。这很令人兴奋。他跑遍了全国，结识了许多人，讲述着他的使命。在某一时刻，他开始确信拯救美国马术队的方法就是让美国军方参与进来。
Because this is who rode-- when I went to the jumping festival in Ireland, the military, or a military program, represented Ireland, and they won. And so I thought the United States should do the same thing, that we should have military riders and military equestrians represent the United States.
因为当我在爱尔兰参加跳跃节时，是军方代表爱尔兰参赛的，而且他们赢了。所以我认为美国也应该这样做，我们应该让军事骑手和军事马术选手代表美国。
So I decided that I would write a letter to Senator Sam Nunn, who was very familiar with defense activity. And I wrote him a letter saying as politely as I could, do you think that the US Army could come up with an equestrian team. And actually, he went off, and his staff researched it for me. And they came back. And I got a letter from somebody in the Pentagon. And they said, "No, I'm sorry. We can't include equestrian in our sports program. We don't have the resources."
所以我决定写信给非常熟悉国防事务的萨姆·纳恩参议员。我在信中尽可能礼貌地询问，您认为美国陆军能组建一支马术队吗？实际上，他确实去做了，他的幕僚为我进行了研究，最后他们回复了我。我收到了五角大楼某人的回信。他们说：“不，很抱歉。我们的体育项目中无法包含马术。我们没有那样的资源。”
After a few years, Robert's mission started to fall apart. He was losing money. The people running the US equestrian team let him know they didn't actually want him to save them. So he stopped.
几年后，罗伯特的使命开始破灭。他一直在亏钱。经营美国马术队的人也让他知道，他们并不真的需要他的拯救。于是他停止了。
And when he looks back on those times these days, he said it was like he was too alive back then, too alive. He says back then, he had a sickness that made him believe every idea with complete conviction, that made him act on every inspired notion that entered his head. Now, he works a normal job, sleeps normal hours, commutes a normal commute, takes medications which protect him from fits of mania.
如今当他回首往事时，他说那时的他感觉太“鲜活”了，太鲜活了。他说那时他患有一种疾病，使他能以绝对的信念相信每一个想法，让他对脑海中出现的每一个灵感都付诸行动。现在，他做着普通的工作，睡着正常的觉，通勤着正常的路线，服用药物来保护自己免受狂躁发作的影响。
I think I was a lot more creative when I was slightly manic. In a way, I was certainly a little bit wilder and maybe a little bit more fun.
我觉得我在轻度狂躁时更有创造力。在某种程度上，我当然更野一点，也可能更有趣一点。
In fact, when he and acquaintances who suffered through similar kinds of mental illness get together, sometimes they'll all reminisce about the old days, before they were medicated.
事实上，当他和经历过类似精神疾病的熟人聚在一起时，有时他们会一起怀念用药之前的那些旧时光。
Oh, yeah. We all talk about how many times we've been arrested or something like that. That's conversation. We talk about the goofy things we did. "I got arrested. I remember that. The police was very nice. But I broke a vase, and he took me to the hospital." And we talk about our hospitalizations.
噢，是的。我们都会聊起我们被捕过多少次之类的话题。这就是我们的谈话内容。我们谈论我们做过的傻事。“我被捕了。我记得那次。警察很友善。但我打碎了一个花瓶，他把我送到了医院。”我们还会聊起住院的经历。
And I do reminisce a little bit about it. It was fun. We had a lot of fun and went all over the country and had friends. And it was kind of exciting, sure.
我也确实会偶尔怀念那段日子。那时很开心。我们有很多乐趣，跑遍了全国，交了很多朋友。那确实挺令人兴奋的，当然。
But now I'm socked in a schedule of being responsible and going to work every day. And these things are not fun compared to running around the country and going to horse shows. Those were more fun. But this is what I've chosen to do.
但现在我被束缚在负责任和每天上班的日程表里。比起跑遍全国去参加马展，这些事情一点也不好玩。那时候确实更有趣。但这是我选择的生活方式。
It doesn't just happen among people who are medicated, the desire to avoid the highs and lows of a frantic life. Many people choose a steadier life, a duller life, because it's also a saner life, or because it's all they can manage. Today on our program, Avoiding the High Cost of Living, people stepping back from one big life experience or another, and why that may be the only possible choice sometimes. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
不仅仅是那些正在服药的人，这种想要逃避狂热生活带来的高潮与低谷的愿望，在其他人身上也同样存在。许多人选择了一种更平稳、更枯燥的生活，因为这也意味着更清醒的生活，或者是因为这已是他们力所能及的一切。今天我们的节目主题是《逃避高昂的生活代价》，关注那些从某种重大生活经历中退出来的人们，以及为什么有时这可能是唯一可能的选择。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台，这里是《这个美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Act One of our program today. How to Avoid the Everyday Irritations of Everyday Life. Jack Hitt talks to a woman who stumbled onto one way, accidentally and against her will. Act Two, How to Avoid the Difficulty of Living With Someone, in which we hear a philosophical defense of baby talk among adults, that's right, baby talk among adults. We hear the grisly details. And do not pretend that you have not been there, my friend. Act Three, How to Avoid Everything. Writer Dani Shapiro explains how a 22-year-old can avoid facing all the important facts about his or her own life. Stay with us.
今天节目的第一幕。《如何逃避日常生活中的日常烦恼》。杰克·希特采访了一位偶然发现了一种方法的女士，虽然这是违背她意愿的。第二幕，《如何逃避与人相处的困难》，我们将听到对成年人之间“宝宝语”的哲学辩护，没错，就是成年人之间的宝宝语。我们将听到其中的细节。别假装你没经历过，我的朋友。第三幕，《如何逃避一切》。作家丹妮·夏皮罗将解释一个22岁的年轻人如何逃避面对他或她生命中所有重要的事实。请继续收听。
Act One, How to Avoid the Everyday Irritations of Everyday Life. No one is in a better position to talk about deadening yourself to life than someone who was forced to do it by nearly dying. Jack Hitt tells the story.
第一幕，《如何逃避日常生活中的日常烦恼》。没有人比那些因濒临死亡而被迫变得麻木的人更有资格谈论如何让自己对生活麻木了。杰克·希特讲述了这个故事。
Back in the 1980s, when Charlene Riling was just out of college, her life was consumed with being a jock. She played basketball until midnight and could always be counted on for a pickup game of baseball or softball. She especially loved her beautiful yellow and purple Bottechia racing bike.
回到20世纪80年代，当查琳·瑞林刚大学毕业时，她的生活完全被运动占据了。她打篮球直到午夜，而且在随叫随到的棒球或垒球比赛中总少不了她的身影。她尤其钟爱她那辆漂亮的黄紫色Bottechia赛车。
It would be nothing to be riding on the Blue Ridge Parkway down in North Carolina and Tennessee, going down on your racing bike, 50, 55 miles an hour. I don't know that I would do that today. So, yes, I felt very invincible and, in that sense, very confident, really that fearless mentality. Which right now, I have to say, subsequent to everything that happened, I've really lost that.
在北卡罗来纳州和田纳西州的蓝岭大道上骑行，骑着赛车以时速50到55英里的速度飞驰，这在当时根本不算什么。我不知道今天我还会不会那样做。所以，是的，我当时感觉自己所向无敌，那种感觉非常自信，真的有一种无畏的心态。我不得不说，在经历了这一切之后，我已经彻底失去了那种心态。
In 1981, Charlene's father died. She'd always thought of him as her best friend, and it almost seemed destined to be that way. He was Charles. She was Charlene. They had the same birthday. She was devastated.
1981年，查琳的父亲去世了。她一直把他视为自己最好的朋友，而且这似乎是注定的。他叫查尔斯，她叫查琳。他们同一天生日。她彻底崩溃了。
Then her girlfriend left her. She started to drink a good bit more and lose herself in the bar scene. A couple of times, she and some friends shot up cocaine for a nice, potent, '80s-style high. Then she cleaned up, went to AA.
随后她的女友也离开了她。她开始喝更多的酒，沉溺于酒吧生活。有几次，她和一些朋友为了寻求80年代那种强烈的快感而注射了可卡因。后来她洗心革面，加入了戒酒互助会。
Years later, in the summer of 1988, the invincible Charlene came down with a weird flu she just couldn't shake. It went on for weeks, then months. She had her suspicions, which flared into a private panic when she found out that a guy she'd shared needles with was positive for HIV. She screwed up the courage to go to the county health department to get an anonymous test, and returned on a cold, gloomy day to receive the results.
多年后，在1988年的夏天，这位“不可战胜”的查琳染上了一种怪异的流感，怎么也治不好。这持续了几个星期，然后是几个月。她心里有了怀疑，当发现曾经和她共用过针头的那个男人艾滋病毒检测呈阳性时，她陷入了私下的恐慌。她鼓起勇气去县卫生局做了匿名检测，并在一个寒冷阴郁的日子回来获取结果。
I remember sitting out in this big, open waiting room. And there wasn't really anybody in there. And I don't remember how many minutes, but it wasn't that long after sitting down that I was told that I was positive at that time.
我记得当时坐在那个宽敞的候诊室里。里面几乎没有人。我不记得具体过了多少分钟，但坐下没多久，我就被告知当时我的结果是阳性。
The counselor then proceeded to go on to her own little religious agenda, going on to say that Jesus Christ heals all those who repent their sins, referring to my lesbianism as being a sin, and that people are cured of AIDS. And AIDS is a sinful disease, and that's how people get it. But you can be cured of it if you repent your sins.
随后，那位咨询师开始宣扬她自己的一套宗教议程，继续说道耶稣基督会治愈所有忏悔罪孽的人，她把我的女同性恋身份称为一种罪孽，并说人们是可以治愈艾滋病的。她说艾滋病是一种罪恶的疾病，这就是人们得病的原因。但只要你忏悔自己的罪孽，就能被治愈。
And it felt like the longest period of my life, being in there, just feeling like you're in one of those little snowy glasses filled with water, and somebody just shook it up. And your head's spinning. And everything's going on. And you want to get out of there, but you can't. And I just felt very trapped.
那是我一生中最漫长的一段时间，待在那里，感觉自己就像被困在那些盛满水的小雪球装饰品里，被人猛烈地摇晃。大脑一片混乱。所有的事情都在发生。你想离开那里，却走不掉。我感到非常绝望。
And then she started talking about this church called Hope Ministries. And Hope Ministries is a place that will convert people from being gay to being straight. And she tried pretty hard to get me to Hope Ministries. And I just took the piece of paper and just left. Never saw the counselor again, never went to Hope Ministries. And that was it.
然后她开始谈论一个叫“希望事工”的教堂。那个事工是个将同性恋转化为异性恋的地方。她非常卖力地想让我去那个“希望事工”。我只是拿过那张纸就离开了。我再也没见过那个咨询师，也从未去过“希望事工”。事情就是这样。
I remember the doctor starting the AZT, started on 500 milligrams. And all this bloodwork was being done. And so my whole life, socially, changed. My social, economical class changed.
我记得医生开始给我开AZT（叠氮胸苷），剂量是500毫克。所有的血液检查都在进行中。我的整个生活，在社交方面，彻底改变了。我的社会和经济阶层也随之改变了。
And did you stop working during this time?
在这期间你停止工作了吗？
Yeah, I actually stopped working just shortly afterwards.
是的，实际上没过多久我就停止工作了。
So you're 30 years old, and you're forced to retire?
所以你才30岁，就被迫退休了？
Right. And work was the most-- to me, my job was the biggest part of-- it was really my identity, the computer person or computer geek. I loved computers before I ever saw what a computer looked like. I just loved it. It was exciting. And it was about to come out from underneath me very quickly, what my whole life was built on.
是的。工作对我来说是最重要的——工作实际上就是我的身份，那个搞电脑的人或者电脑极客。在看到电脑长什么样之前，我就爱上了电脑。我就是爱它。那很令人兴奋。而我整个生活建立的基础，很快就要从我脚下坍塌了。
So you end up with migraines. AZT is known to cause migraines, debilitating migraines. Just bury your head under a pillow, no light. You can't move for days. And they were just awful.
所以你最终患上了偏头痛。众所周知，AZT会导致偏头痛，那种令人虚脱的偏头痛。只能把头埋在枕头下，不见一丝光亮。你可能连续几天都无法动弹。那种感觉真是太可怕了。
My muscles had reached a point where they had atrophied. My hands had closed into a fist. My hand was closed, like clenched, like a fist.
我的肌肉已经萎缩到极限。我的手缩成了拳头。我的手是闭合的，紧紧攥着，像个拳头一样。
I could use my finger and my thumb to barely write with. And it looked probably like cat scratch. It wasn't even legible. And I was also having real chronic and debilitating diarrhea, couldn't even make it to the bathroom.
我只能勉强用手指和拇指写字。那看起来可能就像猫抓的一样。甚至都无法辨认。我还出现了严重的慢性腹泻，令人虚脱，甚至连厕所都赶不上。
And at some point, Prednisone was introduced, which causes muscle wasting and a host of other side effects. And then the combination of all the other medications, in July of 1991, I was admitted to the hospital for changes in mental status. I was diagnosed as having AIDS dementia, AIDS-related dementia.
在某个阶段，开始使用了强的松，这会导致肌肉萎缩和一系列其他副作用。在所有其他药物的共同作用下，1991年7月，我因精神状态改变被送进医院。我被诊断患有艾滋病痴呆症，即艾滋病相关痴呆。
Everything, on one hand, seemed hurried. Death seemed much more inevitable than it just does in daily living. We don't really think about it. We don't plan for our death.
一方面，一切似乎都很匆忙。死亡看起来比日常生活中要不可避免得多。我们平时并不真正去想它。我们不为自己的死亡做计划。
But I had gotten a dog during that time. He's a beagle. His name is Sam. He's nine years old now. And it's like Sam knew. Because Sam was around me the most, because he was home, and I was home.
但我那时候养了一只狗。它是只比格犬。它的名字叫山姆。它现在九岁了。感觉山姆知道。因为山姆大部分时间都陪着我，因为它在家，我也在家。
And it's like I can remember being in bed and crying, just being so afraid of dying. And I couldn't talk about it with my mother. And I really wanted to. But I knew how my mother felt about death. And I didn't want her to know that I was afraid.
我记得躺在床上哭泣，因为太害怕死亡。我无法和母亲谈论这件事。我真的很想谈。但我知道母亲对死亡的看法。我不想让她知道我害怕。
And my biggest fear was what was going to happen with Sam. I used to think about-- Sam used to get so excited when I'd walk in the house. You'd think I was gone for months. I would be gone for a half a day. And it would be like he'd go nuts. And when I came home from the hospital one time, the July '91 hospitalization, and a couple of friends dropped me off. And Sam went nuts all over me.
我最大的恐惧是山姆以后怎么办。我以前常想——山姆以前每次我进屋时都会非常兴奋。你会以为我离开好几个月了。其实我只是离开半天而已。它会像疯了一样。有一次我从医院回来，那是1991年7月那次住院，几个朋友把我送回来。山姆激动地扑到我身上，高兴坏了。
And I kept thinking to myself, when I'm gone, I'm not going to walk back in that door again. And Sam's going to just be waiting for me to come in. And I'm not going to come back in. And I know people might say, "Oh, it's just a dog," but--
我当时一直在想，当我离开后，我就再也不会走进那扇门了。而山姆还会一直等着我进来。但我再也不会回来了。我知道人们可能会说，“哦，那只是一条狗而已”，但是——
Charlene prepared to die. The doctors doubled her AZT and told her she had six months to a year to live. She wrote a will at age 31, appointed an executor to her estate, made arrangements with a hospice to care for her. She said goodbye to all her friends, gave away all her most valued possessions.
查琳为死亡做好了准备。医生将她的AZT剂量加倍，并告诉她只有六个月到一年的生命了。她在31岁时立下了遗嘱，为她的遗产指定了执行人，并安排好了临终关怀中心照顾她。她与所有的朋友告别，送走了所有她最珍视的财物。
I remember when you walked into my little beach cottage, on the right hand wall, I had all my bicycle racing numbers. And this whole wall was just all bicycle memorabilia kind of thing, and pictures of me from when I used to ride and race. And I had kept that up.
我记得当你走进我的小海边小屋时，右手边的墙上，贴满了我的自行车比赛编号。整面墙都是自行车纪念品，还有我以前骑行和比赛时的照片。我一直把它们挂在那。
But I remember one day when I knew that I was never going to be riding again and never be racing again, and just let that anger set in. And I remember just taking all that stuff down, and probably not very gently either, and just feeling like, "That's all gone. It's all gone, and it's never going to happen again." And I just couldn't look at it anymore. It was too painful.
但我记得有一天，当我知道我再也不会骑车，再也不会比赛时，我就任由愤怒吞噬了我。我记得我把那些东西全都取了下来，动作大概也不怎么轻柔，只觉得：“一切都结束了。都结束了，再也不会发生了。”我实在无法再看它们一眼。那太痛苦了。
In her final days, in a lot of pain, Charlene sought out a renegade physician named Gary Blick in Greenwich, Connecticut. He was known for helping AIDS patients get access to often unorthodox therapies. Her regular doctor suggested she avoid him, called him a quack.
在最后的日子里，痛苦不堪的查琳在康涅狄格州格林威治寻找了一位名叫加里·布利克的非主流医生。他以帮助艾滋病患者获得非常规疗法而闻名。她的常规医生建议她避开他，称他是个骗子。
But she was desperate. So she got her friend, Jamie, to drive her down there. And Dr. Blick, as with each new patient, gave her a full workup, including basic blood tests.
但她已经绝望了。于是她让朋友杰米开车带她过去。布利克医生像对待每位新病人一样，为她做了全面的检查，包括基础血液检测。
And I remember sitting there, next to Jamie. And we're both sitting in Gary's office. And you sit out, and you look out. And you see the trees out in the back. And I remember it was a sunny day. It was in spring and everything. There was life outside.
我记得当时坐在杰米旁边。我们俩都坐在加里的办公室里。你坐在那里往外看。你可以看到外面的树木。我记得那是个晴天。当时是春天，一切都很美好。外面充满生机。
And sitting there with Jamie, and Dr. Blick sitting there and telling me, "I have good news for you." And he sat there and told me this good news, that I didn't have HIV, and I didn't have AIDS. And I just sat there like, "This can't be."
我坐在杰米旁边，布利克医生坐在那里告诉我：“我有个好消息要告诉你。”他坐在那里告诉了我这个好消息，说我没有艾滋病毒，也没有艾滋病。我就那么坐着，心想：“这不可能。”
I've been told this. My whole life's been planned about this. You know what I'm saying.
我一直被这样告知。我整个人生都是围绕这一点规划的。你懂我的意思吧。
Did you just assume that he was wrong? Or did you immediately believe him?
你当时是认为他错了？还是你立刻相信了他？
No, I don't know. I don't think that I immediately-- I just couldn't. How do you take one day and compare it to three years?
不，我不知道。我觉得我无法立刻——我只是做不到。你如何用一天的时间去推翻这三年？
One of the classic stages of dying is denial, refusing to accept that you actually have AIDS, fervently believing that the doctor will step out of the lab and say, "Oh, sorry. It's all been a big mistake. You don't have AIDS." And that is precisely what happened to Charlene, after living as an HIV-positive woman for three years.
死亡的经典阶段之一是否认，拒绝接受自己真的患有艾滋病，狂热地相信医生会从实验室走出来说：“哦，抱歉。这一切都是个大错误。你没有艾滋病。”而这正是查琳在以艾滋病阳性身份生活了三年后所发生的事情。
It turned out that back when she first got tested for HIV, the woman at the county health department had deliberately lied to her, told Charlene she was HIV-positive when in fact, the test was negative. She was hoping that Charlene would come to the little ministry church in town and be healed of both her lesbianism and her AIDS. Then, of course, she'd be a documented, verifiable miracle for Jesus.
事实证明，当她最初接受艾滋病检测时，县卫生局的那名女子蓄意对她撒了谎，告诉查琳她是艾滋病阳性，而实际上，检测结果是阴性的。她希望查琳会来到镇上的那个小型福音教堂，从而治愈她的同性恋和艾滋病。然后，当然，她就会成为耶稣所创造的一个有据可查、可被证实的奇迹。
I just broke down and just cried and cried and cried, and just couldn't believe it that I had been betrayed. And I really had been lied to, and that this whole illusion was created for religion, to prove a point, to get me to go to Hope Ministries, to convert from being a lesbian to being straight, and then probably to be set up to be retested again and be told I was negative.
我彻底崩溃了，哭啊哭啊，无法相信自己竟然被背叛了。我确实被骗了，而这一切幻象都是为了宗教目的而制造出来的，为了证明某个观点，为了诱导我去“希望事工”，为了让我从同性恋转变成异性恋，然后大概会安排我再测一次，再告诉我是阴性。
It was more than just losing three years of my life. There was a whole identity and a whole life built around a person with AIDS. I have lived as a person with AIDS. It's the medications that were prescribed, the diagnosis, all the events that took place, AIDS Buddy, AIDS Interfaith, living positively. My whole life was lived as a person with AIDS.
这不仅仅是失去了我三年的生命。我整个人生和身份都是围绕着一个艾滋病患者建立起来的。我一直作为艾滋病患者生活。无论是处方药、诊断结果，还是发生的所有事件，包括艾滋病互助小组、艾滋病宗教间组织，以及积极生活。我整个人生都是作为艾滋病患者度过的。
The AIDS drugs were so powerful, they'd given her the symptoms of a person with AIDS. In addition to AZT, Charlene was fed very powerful steroids, which can bring on dementia-like states. But now she had to be weaned off her complicated drug regimen. Cold turkey would definitely kill her. So she spent a year tapering off her prescription drugs until she could once again enter normal life.
这些艾滋病药物太强了，以至于让她出现了艾滋病人的症状。除了AZT，查琳还服用了非常强力的类固醇，这会引发类似痴呆的状态。但现在她必须戒掉复杂的药物方案。直接停药肯定会要了她的命。于是她花了一年时间逐渐减少处方药的剂量，直到她能重新过上正常生活。
But how does one do that? When Charlene found out she was destined to die, she discovered huge institutions ready to help her, the church, the hospices, the AIDS buddy groups. But now she was told to make a U-turn, to go back to the living, to abandon all her moribund friends, to forget the big philosophical questions and return to a life where she could buy a car and sweat out a mortgage, where she could take a lover safely and get annoyed with her, argue with her about the bills and feeding the dog and cleaning up after dinner and mowing in the back yard. Looking back on it all from a nice, cozy room in a new house in Connecticut, she said in many ways, it was easier dying.
但一个人该怎么做呢？当查琳发现自己注定要死时，她发现了庞大的机构随时准备帮助她，教会、临终关怀中心、艾滋病互助小组。但现在她被告知要掉头，回到生者的世界，抛弃所有垂死的朋友，忘记宏大的哲学问题，回到那个她可以买车、为房贷奔波的生活中，回到那个她可以安全地找个爱人，跟她吵架，为账单、喂狗、饭后清理和修剪后院草坪而争论的生活。从她在康涅狄格州新家的一间舒适房间里回望这一切，她说在很多方面，其实死亡反而更容易。
You know, you start letting go of life's little things that might have set you off or whatever. Those things in life seemed just so insignificant. There was something much bigger than that that was happening.
你知道，你开始放下生活中那些可能让你抓狂的小事。生活中的那些事情看起来是如此微不足道。当时正在发生的事情远比那些重要得多。
The work that it took to get to the edge, and to have gotten really to the end, essentially, to get that far and then to be pulled back. There was one part of me, that wait-- there's some simplicity here. There's some peacefulness here. There's no more insanity of the world and people's politics and people's pushiness, and their beliefs.
为了走到边缘，真正走到尽头，经历了这一切，然后又被拉回来。我心中有一部分觉得——这里有一种简单。这里有一种平静。世界上再也没有了那些疯狂、人们的政治、人们的急躁和他们的各种信仰。
I work hard to keep my life simple today. But I wanted to keep it as simple as it was in that preparation for dying. And you can't do that and live in the real world at the same time.
我今天努力让生活保持简单。但我曾想让它像为死亡做准备时那样简单。而要在现实世界中生活，你是不可能做到这一点的。
Jack Hitt, who put that story together, is a contributing editor to This American Life.
杰克·希特，策划这个故事的人，是《这个美国生活》的特约编辑。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "CALIFORNIA" BY QUASI]
[音乐播放 - Quasi 的 "California"]
Coming up, the social uses of baby talk. That's baby talk among adults. Brace yourself, because it's just one minute away, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，宝宝语的社会用途。我说的是成年人之间的宝宝语。做好心理准备，因为再过一分钟就到，来自国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and reporters to tackle that theme. Today's program, Avoiding the  High Cost of Living. These are stories-- I realize, actually, I've avoided saying this because when you say it out loud, it sounds so depressing. These are stories about people who choose not to live every moment to the fullest, who choose to withdraw from life in some way, to make themselves numb, and stories about why that's sometimes the only choice possible.
这里是《这个美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，邀请各类作家和记者来探讨这个主题。今天节目的主题是《逃避高昂的生活代价》。这些故事——其实我意识到，我一直回避说出这点，因为当你大声说出来时，听起来太压抑了。这些故事是关于那些选择不尽情享受生活每一刻的人，那些选择以某种方式退缩、让自己麻木的人，以及关于为什么这有时是唯一可能的选择的故事。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program, Act Two, How to Avoid the Difficulty of Living With Someone. "Cuteness," a friend with small children once said to me, "is what nature gives to our offspring so we don't kill them." Without cuteness, our species dies off. But then what is the function of cuteness among adults?
我们来到了节目的第二幕，第二幕，《如何逃避与人相处的困难》。“可爱”，一位有小孩的朋友曾对我说，“是自然赋予我们后代的东西，这样我们才不会杀了他们。”没有可爱，我们的物种就会灭绝。但成年人之间可爱的功能又是什么呢？
Consider, please, the role of baby talk among adults. This is speech designed specifically and entirely for cuteness, shared in private. And as I've said, our program today is about all the things that we do to actually avoid experiencing our own lives.
请考虑一下成年人之间“宝宝语”的作用。这种说话方式专为可爱而设计，完全在私下分享。正如我所说，我们今天的节目是关于我们为了逃避体验自己的生活而所做的一切事情。
I would argue that baby talk, cute speech, is one way that we do that. People seldom discuss this in public. Our own producer, Nancy Updike, and her boyfriend, Chicago journalist Adam Davidson, agreed to step forward and speak the truth about the issue.
我想说，宝宝语，这种可爱的说话方式，是我们逃避生活的一种手段。人们很少在公开场合讨论这一点。我们的制片人南希·厄普代克和她的男友，芝加哥记者亚当·戴维森，同意站出来讲述关于这个问题的真相。
You want a shortcut to the intimacy that used to come from just spending hours and hours talking to one another about our lives. Because when you're first falling in love, that's the only thing that you do, and the only thing that you want to do. And you make as much time as possible for just talking to each other. And then as the relationship progresses and other things reassert themselves, work or friends or whatever it is, then you have less time together.
你想走捷径来获得那种曾经只需花数小时聊天就能获得的亲密感。因为当你刚坠入爱河时，那是你唯一会做的事，也是你唯一想做的事。你会尽可能多地腾出时间来只和对方说话。而随着关系的深入，其他事情——工作、朋友之类——重新占据了你的生活，那么你们在一起的时间就少了。
And you want to get that intimacy. And you don't have as much time. So you're trying to sort of make a shortcut to it.
你想要获得那种亲密度，但又没有那么多时间。所以你试图走个捷径。
It happened so fast. In Adam and Nancy's case, they'd be going out only three months when, like twins, or people in captivity, or deserted tribes on remote desert islands, they began developing their own private language. At some point, they found that they were whispering to each other a lot.
这一切发生得太快了。在亚当和南希的例子中，他们交往才三个月，就像双胞胎，或者被囚禁的人，又或是荒岛上的幸存者一样，他们开始发展出自己的私人语言。在某个时刻，他们发现自己经常对着对方耳语。
Well, I feel like that came about a lot on the phone, because Adam works at home. So he calls me a lot during the day, and I call him, too. And then we say, "Hi, how are you doing." And I'll say, "I got to go." And Adam will say, "No, don't go." And I'll say, "I have to go." "No, don't go." "But I have to go." "No."
我觉得那更多是在电话里产生的，因为亚当在家办公。所以他白天经常打电话给我，我也打给他。然后我们说，“嗨，你怎么样。”我会说，“我得走了。”亚当会说，“不，别走。”我会说，“我必须得走。”“不，别走。”“但我必须走。”“不。”
And the key is the whispering.
关键在于耳语。
The whispering, yeah.
耳语，是的。
There's whispering. But it's also like baby talk, like, "No, don't want you to go." "Don't go." "Must go." "Don't go."
会有耳语。但这更像宝宝语，就像，“不，不想让你走。”“别走。”“必须得走。”“别走。”
And so you're doing that. So that starts on the phone, but then you find that it starts to creep to other areas of your life as well?
所以你们在这样做。那是在电话里开始的，但后来你们发现它开始渗透到你们生活的其他方面了？
Right. If you wanted to record baby talk, you'd want to put a mic over our bed when we're going to sleep, because that's when we do it the most. And then it's not baby talk, but it's hitting. There's a lot of--
没错。如果你想录下宝宝语，你会想在我们睡觉时把麦克风放在床上，因为那时我们做得最多。那不只是宝宝语，还有拍打。有很多——
Oh, this is a classic.
噢，这很经典。
I should just say that you just sort of hit her. I don't know how to describe--
我应该说你只是轻拍她。我不知道怎么形容——
But in a very sort of kid way to hit. Not like you'd punch someone. I'd come home at the end of the day and maybe turn on the TV. We're eating dinner and watching TV. And we're kind of quiet.
但那是一种非常孩子气的拍打。不是像你会挥拳打人那样。我一天工作结束回到家，可能会打开电视。我们边吃晚饭边看电视。我们当时比较安静。
And then all the sudden, Adam would just reach out and hit me a little bit. He'd be like "I like you." It was like you would do in first grade. And of course, now I hit back. And I yell, "I like you."
然后突然间，亚当会伸出手轻轻拍我一下。他会说“我喜欢你”。就像你在一年级时做的那样。当然，现在我也回拍他。我大喊，“我喜欢你。”
And that's another whole voice, which is different, like, "I like you." Like I'd be operating the thermostat. And Nancy would be like, "Could you turn it down?" And I'd say, "No, it's too cold." And she'd be like, "No, it's the other cold. It's too hot." And that's a whole genre.
这就是另一种声音了，这不一样，比如，“我喜欢你。”就像我在操作恒温器。南希会说，“你能调低点吗？”我会说，“不行，太冷了。”她会说，“不，是另一种冷。太热了。”这是一整套类型。
Did you mean "turn it up"? "No, I meant the other up, down!" This is definitely the most embarrassing thing that I've ever talked about in public, without any question in my mind.
你是想说“调高”吗？“不，我是说另一个上，向下！”这绝对是我在公共场合谈论过的最尴尬的事情，毫无疑问。
What's amazing is that you talk about sex in public. You talk about money in public. But this, why this?
令人惊奇的是，你们会在公共场合谈论性。你们会在公共场合谈论钱。但这个，为什么是这个？
Because it's completely uncool. There's nothing cool about it. There's no way to make it cool.
因为它完全不酷。它一点也不酷。没办法让它变酷。
You can be outrageous about sex. Or you can make fun of either having a lot of money or having no money. There are ways that you can talk about those things that you can preserve some corner of dignity. But baby talk is completely without any cool or dignity or any sort of redeeming social value. It is truly a dirty little secret, much more than sex.
你可以对性表现得离经叛道。或者你可以拿有很多钱或没钱来开玩笑。有很多谈论这些事情的方式可以让你保留一点尊严。但宝宝语完全不酷，没有尊严，也没有任何社会价值。它确实是一个肮脏的小秘密，比性还要秘密。
And it happens in this protected space, namely privacy.
而且它发生在这样一个受保护的空间里，即隐私空间。
Right, right, exactly. And it's a bit strange, because it's this very performative speech. It is a performance. It's like kabuki. You do it the same way every time. And everyone knows the next move. But it's this performance for one person.
对，对，没错。而且这有点奇怪，因为它是一种表演性极强的语言。这是一场表演。就像歌舞伎。你每次都用同样的方式表演。每个人都知道下一步动作。但这是为了一个人表演。
And then there was this thing where one of us was nicknamed "Schnookie."
然后还有一件事情，你们其中一人被昵称为“Schnookie”。
Oh my god, we cannot, we can't--
天哪，我们不能，我们不能——
Nancy would always know which one was, and I would always forget who--
南希总是知道哪一个是，但我总是忘记谁是——
Well, there was-- OK, if we're going to do this--
好吧，如果有——好吧，如果我们要说这个——
One of you had a nickname. And there were only two of you in the relationship, and you couldn't remember which was which?
你们其中一个人有个昵称。你们关系里只有两个人，你们竟然记不清谁是谁？
No, no, no. One was Schnookie. And then the other one, of course, it's Schlumpy. Because one of you is Schnookie, so logically, the other one must be Schlumpy. Tears of embarrassment are springing to my eyes.
不，不，不。一个是Schnookie。然后另一个，当然，就是Schlumpy。因为其中一个是Schnookie，所以从逻辑上讲，另一个必须是Schlumpy。尴尬的泪水涌上我的眼眶。
But then that becomes a whole thing. Like, "No, wait, are you Schnookie? Hey, Schnook. G'night, Schnook."
但这随后变成了一整套东西。比如，“不，等等，你是Schnookie吗？嘿，Schnook。晚安，Schnook。”
I remember that we were lying in bed together. And we were going back and forth. We were just talking before going to sleep. And we were going back and forth in one of the ways that we had at that time.
我记得我们躺在床上。我们来回说着话。睡前我们只是聊天。我们用当时那种方式来回交谈。
"You're taking the covers." "No, you." "I want that blanket. No, that blanket, the other blanket, the one blanket." "Come here, Schlumpy." "Oh, Schnookie." Whatever it was.
“你在抢被子。”“不，是你。”“我要那条毯子。不，那条毯子，另一条毯子，那条毯子。”“过来，Schlumpy。”“噢，Schnookie。”不管是什么。
And I just felt like I was going to cry. I just felt so full of despair. And I said, "Can we stop talking this way?" And then, what did you say?
我当时觉得我快要哭了。我感到内心充满了绝望。我说，“我们能停止这样说话吗？”然后，你说了什么？
Well, I remember feeling like been a tough few weeks. Each of us had had a lot of tough times in work, and didn't have a lot of time together, because we were so busy. And I remember it had been days of just me feeling like, "I don't even know her, and she doesn't know--" And when you're that close, you just feel like, "I don't know me."
嗯，我记得那几周过得很艰难。我们俩在工作中都遇到了很多困难，在一起的时间很少，因为我们太忙了。我记得那是连续几天，我感觉“我甚至不认识她，而她也不认识——”当你亲近到那种程度，你会觉得，“我甚至不认识我自己。”
And I just had wanted to say something about this baby talk for so long. But first of all, I couldn't think to say anything outside of baby talk. And second of all, I thought it would really hurt her. And so when she said it, it was just, what a relief.
我真的很想说出关于这些宝宝语的事情，但我首先想不出除了宝宝语之外该说什么。其次，我以为这真的会伤害她。所以当她说出来时，那真是一种解脱。
And I remember beginning to talk like, "You're right. We should talk in a serious way." And it was like finding a new mouth and finding a new tongue and finding a new way of moving all of it and expressing myself that felt, in a way, more false than the baby talk, just because it felt unpracticed and artificial and deliberate.
我记得开始说话就像，“你是对的。我们应该认真地交流。”那感觉就像找到了一个新的嘴，一个新的舌头，一个新的表达方式，这让我觉得，在某种程度上，比宝宝语更虚假，仅仅因为它感觉生疏、人工且刻意。
You know, when you're in a couple, you're both actually in a couple. And then you're pretending to be in a couple at the same time.
你知道，当你处在一段关系中，你们实际上是在一段关系中。同时你们又在假装处在一段关系中。
Yeah, totally. Yeah, we've talked about this.
是的，完全是。是的，我们讨论过这个。
You have? What do you say?
你们讨论过？你们说什么？
I think it's really nice to pretend sometimes. Like sometimes, being in a mature relationship is just not what I want to do, because pretending does have its advantages sometimes. Pretending does let you avoid things for a couple days, which sometimes is what you need and is OK.
我觉得有时候假装一下真的很好。有时候，处在一段成熟的关系中并不是我想要的，因为假装有时确实有它的好处。假装能让你逃避现实几天，而这有时正是你所需要的，也没什么大不了。
I think fake intimacy that seems real is much easier, and it's much more seamless. Because there's nothing to disrupt the flow of it. You never get angry, and you never hate each other.
我觉得看似真实的虚假亲密关系更容易，也更天衣无缝。因为没有什么能破坏它的流动性。你永远不会生气，永远不会互相厌恶。
And you're never just annoyed. And you're never bored. And you're never anything that would interrupt that readout of intimacy. Nothing like that ever happens. And then, yeah, it's easier to pretend to be a happy couple than to be a happy couple.
你也永远不会只是恼火。你永远不会厌倦。你永远不会有任何会中断那种亲密感的事情。那样的事情永远不会发生。然后，是的，假装是一对幸福的伴侣比真正做一对幸福的伴侣更容易。
It's easier to baby talk.
说宝宝语更容易。
Yeah.
是的。
Did you feel and do you feel that you're actually in danger, that there's something that you could lose?
你是否觉得，而且你现在是否觉得你们实际上处于危险之中，有些东西你们可能会失去？
Yes, definitely.
是的，肯定的。
And what is the thing that you could lose?
你们可能会失去的东西是什么？
The actual the substance of the relationship. That sounds too cold, but I felt like I'm losing this person that I fell in love with and that I am in love with.
关系的实质。这听起来太冷酷了，但我感觉我正在失去这个我坠入爱河并与之相爱的人。
When I'm in that kind of baby talk, pretend intimacy, it's impossible to imagine real intimacy and real connection, or just a real conversation. Even in my mind, I think of it through that baby talk. Just remembering, real conversations are suddenly baby talk conversations.
当我处于那种宝宝语、假装的亲密状态时，想象真实的亲密和真正的联系，或者仅仅是一场真正的谈话都是不可能的。甚至在我的脑海中，我也会通过那种宝宝语来思考。回想起来，真正的谈话突然都变成了宝宝语谈话。
"I want a good relationship." "No, I want a good relationship."
“我想要一段好的关系。”“不，我想要一段好的关系。”
Well, I remember when this happened, the first time it happened, because of course, now it happens twice a week.
嗯，我记得当这事发生时，第一次发生的时候，因为当然，现在它一周发生两次。
It happens twice a week that you actually have to say, "Oh, wait, now I will be an adult again"?
你们一周有两次实际上必须说，“哦，等等，现在我又要变回成年人了”？
I think it depends. We're pretty--
我想这取决于情况。我们相当——
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, that's so interesting. You mean that the pull of this sort of fakey--
噢，那太有趣了。你是说这种虚假的——
No, it 's a chronic condition, definitely. It's like TB. Once you test positive, you have to always watch for it.
不，这是一种慢性病，肯定的。就像肺结核。一旦检测呈阳性，你必须时刻提防。
Because it's just like a warm bath. It's the easiest thing in the world to do. It's just like falling down and just hitting the ground.
因为它就像一个温暖的浴缸。这是世界上最容易做的事情。就像摔倒在地一样简单。
It's like a vaudeville routine that the two have you been doing together for 30 years. He says his line. You say your line. The audience laughs. Everything happens the way it's supposed to.
这就像一段你们俩已经一起表演了30年的杂耍节目。他说他的台词。你说你的台词。观众笑了。一切都按照预想的那样进行。
Nancy Updike and Adam Davidson.
南希·厄普代克和亚当·戴维森。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "BABY TALK" BY BILLY IDOL]
[音乐播放 - 比利·爱多的 "Baby Talk"]
Act Three, How to Avoid Everything. It's possible to turn off your emotions and go into autopilot for brief periods with the person you love. And it's also possible to shut your feelings down completely, as in this memoir from writer Dani Shapiro.
第三幕，《如何逃避一切》。在与爱人相处时，暂时关闭情感并进入自动驾驶状态是可能的。完全关闭你的感觉也是可能的，正如作家丹妮·夏皮罗的这篇回忆录所述。
Here, in no particular order, are some things Lenny told me. That he and his wife didn't sleep in the same bed, that they hadn't had a real marriage in years. That she was undergoing electroshock treatment in a clinic outside Philadelphia. That he had cancer and had to fly to Houston three days a week for chemotherapy.
以下是莱尼告诉我的事情，没有特定顺序。他和妻子不在同一张床上睡觉，他们多年来都没有过真正的婚姻生活。她正在费城郊外的一家诊所接受电击治疗。他患有癌症，每周必须飞三次休斯敦接受化疗。
That his youngest daughter, age three, had a rare form of childhood leukemia. That he could not get a divorce for all of the above reasons. That he was heartbroken that he could not leave his wife and marry me.
他三岁的小女儿患有一种罕见的儿童白血病。由于上述所有原因，他无法离婚。他很心碎，因为他无法离开妻子和我结婚。
For a long time, I believed him. With every bone in my body, I trusted that Lenny Klein was telling me the truth. When we talked about it, his jaw would tighten, and his big brown eyes would fill with tears. His voice would quaver with pent-up, complex feelings that I couldn't possibly begin to understand.
很长一段时间，我都相信他。我全身心地信任莱尼·克莱恩告诉我的都是真相。当我们谈论这些时，他的下巴会紧绷，他那双棕色的大眼睛里会充满泪水。他的声音会因无法抑制的复杂情绪而颤抖，而那是我根本无法理解的。
Poor Lenny. I marveled that so many bad things could happen to one person. And I vowed to take care of him. Writing late at night in my extensive journals, I exhorted myself to be a real woman, one who could step up to the plate and be good to her man in his moment of crisis.
可怜的莱尼。我惊叹于一个人身上竟然会发生这么多不幸的事。我发誓要照顾他。在深夜写下密密麻麻的日记时，我鼓励自己做一个真正的女人，一个能在男人遭遇危机时挺身而出、对他好的女人。
Years later, I hold Lenny's lies up to the light and examine my own reasons for believing what, in retrospect, seems preposterous. I reread my old journals and notice the way my girlish handwriting deteriorated into a scrawl as I wrote, "I have to be there for Lenny. He needs me, and he's going through so much. I don't know if I can handle it, but I have to be strong." I try to remember that Lenny was a trial lawyer, that he built an international reputation based on his own pathology, that he lied with an almost evangelical conviction. He prided himself on being able to convince anyone of anything.
多年后，我把莱尼的谎言放在光下审视，并检视我自己相信那些事后看来极其荒谬谎言的原因。我重读旧日记，注意到我少女般的笔迹变得潦草，当时我写道：“我必须陪在莱尼身边。他需要我，他经历了这么多。我不知道自己能不能应付，但我必须坚强。”我试着记住莱尼是一名辩护律师，他基于自己的病态建立了国际声誉，他以一种近乎狂热的信念撒谎。他以能说服任何人相信任何事而自豪。
Paris, 1985. We are walking along the Boulevard Saint-Germain on a cloudless spring day. The rooftops of the Left Bank are creamy against a rare blue sky. And the air outside Cafe Flore smells of croissants and the acrid smoke of Gitane. But I don't notice.
巴黎，1985年。在一个无云的春日，我们走在圣日耳曼大道上。左岸的屋顶在稀有的蓝天下显得奶油般润泽。花神咖啡馆外空气中弥漫着羊角面包的香气和吉坦香烟刺鼻的烟味。但我没注意到。
In Paris, in 1985, I only see what is within one square foot of me, too busy feeling the complicated stew of sensations being with Lenny provokes. I am hung over, floating on a wave of last night's Puligny-Montrachet and a four star dinner that wound up in the toilet of the Hotel Ritz. Lenny's arm is around me, thick and proprietary. I have not read a newspaper or spoken to a soul other than Lenny for weeks now.
1985年的巴黎，我只能看到周围一平方英尺内的东西，因为忙于感受与莱尼在一起所引发的复杂心情而无暇他顾。我宿醉未醒，漂浮在昨晚普里尼-蒙哈谢葡萄酒和一顿以酒店厕所收场的四星级晚餐带来的余韵中。莱尼的手搂着我，厚实且占有欲十足。几周来，除了莱尼，我没读过报纸，也没和任何人说过话。
I've been living the kind of unbelievable life people glide through in airport novels. We have been to London, Monte Carlo, the Cote d'Azur. I have played blackjack in private clubs with oil sheiks, who asked me to blow on their dice for good luck. I wear dark glasses and haute couture suits, a gold watch, and a long, thick strand of pearls. I have no idea who I am.
我过着人们在机场小说中才会滑过的难以置信的生活。我们去过伦敦、蒙特卡洛、蔚蓝海岸。我和石油大亨在私人俱乐部玩过二十一点，他们让我对着骰子吹气祈求好运。我戴着深色墨镜，穿着高级定制套装，戴着金表和一长串珍珠项链。我不知道我是谁。
Lenny steers us onto a narrow side street off the Boulevard Saint-Germain and into a children's clothing store, filled with embroidered dresses my mother used to buy me as a child. He tells me he wants to buy a dress for his youngest daughter, the one with the rare form of leukemia. I help him look through racks of tiny dresses suitable for a three-year-old until we find one he deems perfect, a pale, yellow silk smock with a Peter Pan collar.
莱尼带着我们拐进圣日耳曼大道旁的一条小街，走进一家童装店，里面装满了母亲小时候常给我买的那种绣花裙子。他告诉我他想为他最小的女儿买一条裙子，就是那个患有罕见白血病的女儿。我帮他翻看架子上那些适合三岁孩子穿的小裙子，直到我们找到了他认为完美的款式，一件带有彼得潘领的淡黄色丝绸罩衫。
He holds it up to the sunlight, and his eyes fill with tears. "She'll never live to outgrow this dress," he whispers, "my baby girl." He has layered his lies one on top of the other until they have become opaque, an elaborate construction resembling reality.
他把它举到阳光下，眼里满是泪水。“她永远活不到长出这条裙子的时候了，”他低语道，“我的宝贝女儿。”他把谎言一层层堆叠，直至变得不透明，构建成了一个酷似现实的复杂结构。
He is fond of quoting probably the only line he knows from Franz Kafka. "White is black, and black is white," he often says with a sigh. I never knew exactly what he meant by this. But it seemed to have a lot to do with my life at the time.
他喜欢引用弗朗茨·卡夫卡大概也是他唯一知道的一句话。“白色是黑色，黑色是白色，”他常常叹着气说。我从不确切知道他这话是什么意思。但它似乎与我当时的生活有很大关系。
The lies had small beginnings. Lenny called me from a business trip and told me he was at Montreal Airport, waiting to catch a flight to Calgary. I checked with the airline and found out that the flight would take approximately five hours. So when Lenny called an hour later to say he had landed in Calgary, I very calmly asked him where he really was. "Calgary," he said. "No, Lenny, really." He stuck to his story. In the time that I knew him, he never, ever changed his story midstream.
谎言开始于小事。莱尼从出差途中给我打电话，告诉我他在蒙特利尔机场，等着转机去卡尔加里。我向航空公司查询，发现飞行时间大约需要五个小时。所以当莱尼一小时后打电话说他已经降落在卡尔加里时，我非常冷静地问他到底在哪里。“卡尔加里，”他说。“不，莱尼，说实话。”他坚持自己的说法。在我认识他的这段时间里，他从未，绝对从未中途改变过他的谎言。
I hung up on him and called his family's house in Westchester. When the maid answered the phone, I asked to speak with Mr. Klein. And when he picked up the extension, and I heard his rough, craggy "Hello," I screamed so hard into his ear that he dropped the receiver.
我挂了他的电话，给他在威彻斯特的家里打了电话。当佣人接电话时，我要求找克莱恩先生。当他拿起分机，听到他粗哑的“喂”声时，我对着他的耳朵尖叫，以至于他丢掉了听筒。
He raced into the city. He let himself into my apartment and found me curled up in bed. He scooped me up and held me to his chest.
他驱车赶往城里。他溜进我的公寓，发现我缩在床上。他把我抱起来，紧紧贴在胸口。
His wife wasn't home, he told me. She was having shock treatment. And someone had to take care of his daughter. He hadn't wanted to tell me because he'd wanted to spare me, to protect me from the horror of his life. Surely I understood.
他告诉我，他妻子不在家。她正在接受电击治疗。有人必须照顾他的女儿。他不想告诉我，因为他想保护我，让我免受他生活恐怖的折磨。难道我不理解吗？
"Shh, sweetheart," he murmured into the top of my head as I wept, my face beet red like a little girl's. "So many people need me," he said, "But I love you best of all."
“嘘，亲爱的，”当我哭泣时，他在我的头顶低语，我的脸涨得通红，像个小女孩一样。“这么多人需要我，”他说，“但我最爱你。”
Two years have passed, and something has gone wrong, terribly wrong, with my life. I don't, in fact, think of my life as "my life," but rather as a series of random events that have no logical connection. I am no longer a student. I dropped out of Sarah Lawrence after my junior year, supposedly to pursue acting. And I'm actually doing a pretty good imitation of an actress. But I'm doing an even better imitation of a mistress.
两年过去了，我的生活出了一些问题，非常严重的问题。事实上，我不认为我的生活是“我的生活”，而是一系列没有逻辑联系的随机事件。我不再是学生了。大三后我从莎拉·劳伦斯学院退学，据说是因为想追求演艺事业。我确实在进行不错的演员模仿秀。但我模仿情妇模仿得更好。
Lenny's been busy buying me things. I don't particularly want these things, but they seem to be what Lenny is offering in lieu of himself. So quite suddenly, overnight really, I find myself driving a black Mercedes convertible. And just in case I might be mistaken for anything other than a kept woman, I wear a mink coat, a Cartier watch, a Bulgari necklace with an ancient coin at its center.
莱尼一直忙着给我买东西。我并不特别想要这些东西，但它们似乎是莱尼代替他自己所提供的东西。所以很突然地，一夜之间，我发现自己开上了一辆黑色奔驰敞篷车。为了防止被误认为除了被包养的女人之外的任何身份，我穿着貂皮大衣，戴着卡地亚手表，戴着一条以古币为中心的宝格丽项链。
The Mercedes is a step down from the first car Lenny gave me when we had been going out for a month, a leased Ferrari. I don't know how to drive a stick shift, so the Ferrari was a bit of a problem. What I must have looked like, a 20-year-old blonde dressed like Ivana Trump, stalled in traffic, grinding gears, trying to find the point on the clutch to hold that ridiculous car in place.
这辆奔驰车比我们交往一个月时莱尼给我的第一辆车——一辆租来的法拉利——差了一档。我不知道怎么开手动挡，所以那辆法拉利有点麻烦。我当时看起来一定像个打扮成伊万娜·特朗普的20岁金发女郎，在交通堵塞中熄火，磨损齿轮，试图找到离合器的点来hold住那辆荒唐的车。
Lenny rented an apartment on a pretty little street in Greenwich Village, a furnished triplex with a garden, a fireplace, and a bedroom with a four-poster bed. He called it "our house," as if he didn't have another home with a whole family in it an hour north of the city. He kept half a dozen suits in the bedroom closet, and a brand new silk robe hung behind the bathroom door. There was an entire floor we didn't use, a large, airy children's nursery.
莱尼在格林威治村一条漂亮的小街上租了一间公寓，一套带花园、壁炉和带四柱床卧室的精装修三层复式公寓。他称之为“我们的家”，仿佛他没有在城北一小时车程外还有另一个带着一大家子的家。他在卧室衣橱里挂了半打西装，浴室门后挂着一件崭新的丝绸睡袍。那里还有一整层我们没用到的空间，一个宽敞、通风的儿童育儿室。
My parents knew that something was up. They knew I was going out with somebody, but they had no idea who. I was drifting away from them. And they were letting me go.
我父母知道出事了。他们知道我在和某人交往，但不知道是谁。我正在疏远他们。而他们也正在放手。
One night, I invited them over for dinner. I pushed all traces of Lenny out of sight. But of course, there were clues, a glossy brochure for Italian yachts, a humidor in the center of the coffee table, a man's Burberry overcoat on a hook near the front door. I cooked up a storm, and the place was filled with homey smells-- garlic, basil, coriander. It was winter, and the snow was piled up on the sills. Spotlights in the back yard shone on the landscaped garden, the redwood table, the Adirondack chairs, and the huge, terra cotta pots of last spring's dead geraniums. I had my father's favorite music, Dvorak's Symphony for the New World, playing on the stereo system.
一天晚上，我邀请他们过来吃晚餐。我把莱尼的所有痕迹都清除了。但当然，还是有线索，一本意大利游艇的精美宣传册，茶几中间的雪松木雪茄盒，前门附近挂钩上的一件巴宝莉男式大衣。我做了一大桌子菜，屋子里充满了家常的味道——大蒜、罗勒、香菜。那是个冬天，窗台上积满了雪。后院的聚光灯照在景观花园、红木桌、阿迪朗达克椅，以及去年春天死掉的天竺葵的巨大陶罐上。我在音响系统上播放着我父亲最爱的音乐，德沃夏克的《新世界交响曲》。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "SYMPHONY  NO. 9" BY ANTONIN DVORAK]
[音乐播放 - 安东宁·德沃夏克的《第九交响曲》]
My parents rang the doorbell. They looked so solid standing on my front stoop, their cold, red noses poking out from above their mufflers. If nothing else, they looked like they belonged together. They were elegant and rangy, similarly proportioned, unlike Lenny and me. Lenny is thick as a linebacker, and I had become so delicate, the wind could have picked me up and blown me away. My mother strode into the brownstone as if it wasn't the weirdest thing in the world to be visiting her daughter in a lavish apartment with no name on the outside buzzer. My father trailed behind her wearily, as if setting foot on another planet.
我父母按了门铃。他们站在我家门廊上看起来非常敦实，冰冷红润的鼻尖从围巾上方探出来。至少，他们看起来像是一对。他们优雅且修长，体型相称，不像莱尼和我。莱尼像个线卫一样壮实，而我变得如此脆弱，风一吹就能把我带走。母亲大步走进这栋褐石建筑，仿佛访问住在一个外面门铃上没写名字的豪华公寓里的女儿并不是世界上最怪异的事情。父亲疲惫地跟在她身后，仿佛踏上了另一个星球。
My mother entered the living room, flung her arms wide, and did an impromptu dance to Dvorak. "Tra-la-la-la," she trilled. My father and I hung back and watched, our faces crumpled into awkward smiles.
母亲走进客厅，张开双臂，随着德沃夏克的音乐跳了一段即兴舞蹈。“啦啦啦，”她轻哼道。父亲和我退后看着，我们的脸扭曲成尴尬的笑容。
We were used to it. In every family, there is room for only one Sarah Bernhardt, and my mother had assumed that role. It didn't occur to me that she was frightened, that this was a lot for her to take in, her college dropout daughter living in the lap of luxury. All I could see was her outsized self twirling around my living room in her fur coat and boots. I wanted a drink.
我们习惯了。在每个家庭里，只能容纳一个莎拉·贝尔纳，而我母亲承担了这个角色。我没意识到她是害怕的，这对她来说实在难以消化，她那个辍学的女儿住在这个极其奢华的地方。我眼里只有她那庞大的身影，穿着皮草大衣和靴子在我客厅里旋转。我想喝酒。
I walked over to my mother and put a hand on her shoulder, and she spun to a halt. I took her coat and my father's and hung them above Lenny's raincoat by the front door. For the first time, I noticed there was a wreath made of twigs, a bit of Americana, on the wall near the kitchen. And I wondered if I could remove it quickly before my father saw it.
我走向母亲，把手搭在她肩上，她转动着停了下来。我拿过她和父亲的大衣，挂在门边莱尼的雨衣上方。我第一次注意到厨房附近的墙上有一个用树枝做的花环，一种美式的小装饰。我在想能不能在父亲看到之前迅速把它取下来。
Wreaths under any circumstances are as goyishe as it gets. Which would be worse for my father, imagining that I was with some powerful guy old enough to be my father, or the possibility that the guy wasn't Jewish? I wished I could reassure him, yes Daddy, he's Jewish. 23 years older than me, a pathological liar, married to a woman who knows nothing of me, and a Jew.
在任何情况下，花环都带有极其浓郁的非犹太风味。对父亲来说，哪种情况更糟呢？想象我和一个大到足以做我父亲的强力男人在一起，还是这个男人根本不是犹太人的可能性？我希望我可以让他放心，是的爸爸，他是犹太人。比我大23岁，一个病态的谎言家，娶了一个对我一无所知的女人的犹太人。
I poured myself two glasses of chardonnay for my parents and a large vodka for myself. I figured that if the vodka was in a water glass, they wouldn't know the difference, especially if I drank it like it was water. My drinking had taken on a new urgency in the past few months. It was no longer a question of desire, but of need. I could not get through an evening like this without the armor of booze.
我为父母倒了两杯霞多丽，为自己倒了一大杯伏特加。我想如果伏特加倒在水杯里，他们就不会看出区别，尤其是如果我像喝水一样喝它的话。过去几个月里，我的酗酒有了一种新的紧迫感。那不再是一个愿望的问题，而是一个需求的问题。如果没有酒作为盔甲，我无法度过这样的夜晚。
I handed them their wine and directed them to the couch. On the coffee table, I had put out a plate of crudites and a bowl of olives. "Quite a place," my mother said brightly, her gaze darting around the room at the white brick fireplace with its wrought iron tools, the glass wall overlooking the garden, the soaring ceiling. My father stared at the fringe of the rug, glassy-eyed. He needed to be as numbed as I did to get through this night. "Thanks," I murmured, as if she was paying me a compliment.
我递给他们葡萄酒，示意他们坐在沙发上。茶几上，我放了一盘蔬菜拼盘和一碗橄榄。“真是个好地方，”母亲轻快地说，目光在屋里扫视，看向带铁制工具的白砖壁炉、俯瞰花园的玻璃墙、高耸的天花板。父亲神情呆滞地盯着地毯的边缘。为了度过这个夜晚，他也需要像我一样麻木。我低声说了声“谢谢”，仿佛她是在赞美我。
I checked on dinner, using the opportunity to gulp some wine from the open bottle in the fridge. Vodka and white wine was a combination I knew worked for me. If I stuck with the formula, things shouldn't be too bad in the morning, especially if I wasn't eating. And I couldn't see myself eating.
我检查了一下晚餐，趁机从冰箱里开着的酒瓶里猛喝了几口酒。伏特加加白葡萄酒是我知道对我有效的组合。如果我坚持这个配方，明早应该不会太糟糕，尤其是如果我不吃东西的话。而且我没法想象自己能吃下去。
The music had stopped by the time we all sat at the dining room table, but I didn't notice then. If I had, I would certainly have changed the tape, filled the air with something other than the tinny, lonely sound of our three forks scraping against plates. I pushed my chicken from one side of my plate to the other. My stomach clenched and growled in protest.
当我们坐在餐桌旁时，音乐已经停了，但我当时没注意。如果注意到了，我一定会换一盘磁带，让空气中充满除了我们三把叉子刮擦盘子的那种刺耳、孤独声之外的东西。我把鸡肉从盘子的一边推到另一边。我的胃紧缩着，发出抗议的咕噜声。
It seems that my parents and I, after 22 years in each other's company, had run out of things to say. I already knew their views on the political situation in Israel. And we couldn't discuss my school work. I was no longer in school.
似乎我的父母和我，在彼此陪伴22年之后，已经无话可说了。我已经知道他们对以色列政治局势的看法。而且我们不能讨论我的学业。我已不在学校读书了。
My father pressed a corner of his napkin to his lips and murmured something about the food being delicious. My mother agreed. "My wonderful daughter," she said, shaking her head, "You've turned into such a little homemaker." I looked at my parents across the table. Is that what they really thought? How could they just sit there?
父亲用餐巾纸的一角按了按嘴唇，低声说了句食物很美味。母亲表示赞同。“我出色的女儿，”她摇着头说，“你已经变成了一个如此精明的小管家。”我看着桌子对面的父母。他们真的这么想吗？他们怎么能就那么坐着？
Some small piece of me wanted my father to fling me over his shoulder and carry me, kicking and screaming, to the car he had parked outside. I secretly wished that they would drive me home, deposit me in my childhood bedroom, and feed me chicken soup and saltines. I wanted to start my life over again, but I didn't know how.
我内心深处有一小部分希望父亲能把我扛在肩上，带着踢踢打打、尖叫的我走到他停在外面的车上。我私下希望他们能带我回家，把我安置在儿时的卧室里，喂我喝鸡汤和吃饼干。我想重新开始我的生活，但我不知道该怎么做。
In the face of the most tangible proof that Lenny had been lying to me all these years, I remained with him. "My little girl is dying," he would say whenever I noticed the discrepancies in his stories, or, "My children's mother is having electroshock therapy." When I couldn't take my own confusion anymore-- was Lenny lying to me? Was I going crazy? I decided to hire a detective to get to the bottom of it. By this time, my parents knew all about me and Lenny in theory, but it wasn't something we could talk about.
面对莱尼多年来一直在对我撒谎的最实质性证明，我还是留在了他身边。“我的小女孩快死了，”每当我注意到他故事里的矛盾时，他就会这样说，或者说，“我孩子的母亲正在接受电击治疗。”当我自己实在无法承受这种困惑时——莱尼在对我撒谎吗？我疯了吗？我决定雇一个侦探来查个水落石出。到这时，我的父母在理论上都知道关于我和莱尼的一切，但这不是我们能谈论的话题。
When I think back to my younger self rifling through the New York City Yellow Pages in search of a private investigator, I feel like I'm watching a movie about someone else, a girl so clueless, she really didn't know that her desire to hire a detective was all the answer she needed. I chose a detective agency based on nothing more than its good address in the east 60s, a neighborhood filled with private schools and shrinks. "This isn't what you think," I told the detective. "I'm in a relationship with a married man, and I want you to find out if my boyfriend is cheating on me with his wife." At this, his eyebrows shot up. "Come again?"
每当我回想起年轻的自己翻遍纽约黄页寻找私家侦探时，我感觉像在看一部关于别人的电影，那个女孩太迟钝了，她真不知道她想雇侦探这一行为本身就是她需要的所有答案。我选择那家侦探社仅仅是因为它在东60街有个好地址，那是个挤满了私立学校和心理医生的街区。“这不像你想的那样，”我告诉侦探。“我和一个已婚男人在交往，我想让你查查我男友是不是在和他的妻子偷情。”听到这话，他眉毛挑得老高。“再说一遍？”
"He claims his wife is in a mental hospital. He told me he hasn't been with her in years." "And you think he might be lying," said the investigator. Did I see the laughter behind his eyes, or is my memory supplying it now? Because I simply cannot imagine a middle-aged man listening to an earnest, overdressed 22-year-old girl tell him that she thinks her boyfriend might still be sleeping with his wife. "Yes," I said.
“他声称他的妻子在精神病院。他告诉我他多年没跟她在一起了。”“而你认为他可能在撒谎，”调查员说。我是看到了他眼中的笑意，还是我的记忆在添油加醋？因为我简直无法想象一个中年男人听着一个一本正经、穿戴过度的22岁女孩告诉他，她认为她的男友可能还在和妻子睡觉时的情景。“是的，”我说。
Days later, I got the proof about Lenny's lies. In tears, I called my mother. "Oh, darling, I'm so sorry. Is there anything I can do?" "I don't think so." A pause. "Do you want me to call his wife?" My mother and Mrs. Klein had met each other at a few school functions back when none of this could have struck anyone as a remote possibility. "Yes," I said, "Call her." "I'll do it right now," my mother said.
几天后，我得到了关于莱尼谎言的证据。我含着泪给母亲打电话。“噢，亲爱的，我很难过。有什么我能做的吗？”“我想没有。”沉默片刻。“你想让我给他妻子打电话吗？”母亲和克莱恩太太曾在几次学校活动上见过面，那时还没人觉得这一切有发生的可能。“是的，”我说，“打电话给她。”“我现在就打，”母亲说。
I sat by the phone and watched the minutes tick by. I pictured Lenny's wife answering the phone with a chirpy hello, and my mother's slow, steady explanation of why she was calling. I had set in motion a chain of events which was now unstoppable.
我坐在电话机旁，看着分分秒秒过去。我脑海中浮现出莱尼妻子接电话时那轻快的喂声，以及母亲缓慢、坚定地解释她为什么打电话。我启动了一连串现在已无法停止的事件。
More than 20 minutes passed before my mother called me back. "Well, I did it," she said. "You talked to her?" The world felt unreal, hallucinatory. "Yes. She called me a liar. She told me she has a happy marriage to a man who travels a lot, that he's on his way to California. And I said, 'No, he's on his way to see my daughter.'" My mother sounded proud of herself, immersed in the drama of the moment.
过了20多分钟，母亲才回电给我。“嗯，我做了，”她说。“你和她谈过了？”世界感觉变得不真实，产生幻觉了。“是的。她骂我是个骗子。她告诉我她和一位经常出差的丈夫有着幸福的婚姻，他正在去加州的路上。我说，‘不，他正在去看我女儿的路上。’”母亲听起来对自己很满意，沉浸在当下的戏剧感中。
"How did she seem?" I asked. "What do you mean?" "Lenny's wife, was she angry?" "No," my mother said slowly. "She just didn't believe me, Dani."
“她看起来怎么样？”我问。“你什么意思？”“莱尼的妻子，她生气了吗？”“不，”母亲缓缓地说。“她只是不相信我，丹妮。”
I spent the rest of that day in a state of awful excitement. Something was going to happen. And when Lenny showed up that evening at the apartment we were still sharing in the West Village, I was ready. He put his bags down and gave me a hug.
那一天剩下的时间我都在一种可怕的兴奋中度过。一定会发生点什么的。当莱尼那天晚上出现在我们在西村共享的公寓里时，我准备好了。他放下包，拥抱了我一下。
The phone rang. My mother had given Mrs. Klein the number at the apartment and suggested she find out for herself what her husband was up to. Lenny picked up the phone on the kitchen wall. "Hello?" I watched him. And for the first and only time in the years I knew him, he looked genuinely surprised.
电话响了。母亲给了克莱恩太太公寓的电话号码，并建议她自己去查查她丈夫在搞什么鬼。莱尼拿起厨房墙上的电话。“喂？”我看着他。这是我认识他的这些年来，第一次也是唯一一次，他看起来真的很惊讶。
He didn't say a word. He just listened for a few minutes, then hung up the phone. "That was my wife," he said. I was silent. "How did she get this number?" I shrugged. "I have to go." "I'd imagine," I said faintly. My anger was giving me the fuel that I needed to stay strong, at least for the moment.
他没说一句话。他只是听了几分钟，然后挂断了电话。“那是我妻子，”他说。我沉默不语。“她是怎么得到这个号码的？”我耸了耸肩。“我得走了。”“我猜也是，”我虚弱地说。愤怒给了我保持坚强所需的燃料，至少在这一刻。
When Lenny slammed out of the apartment, I was certain I would never seen him again. I knew the truth now. It was staring me in the face, in the concrete form of flight lists and photos. And he knew that I knew. And besides, the whistle was blown. What could he possibly tell his wife? This was it, I told myself, absolutely, positively, the end.
当莱尼摔门离开公寓时，我确信我再也不会见到他了。我现在知道了真相。它正以航班列表和照片的具体形式呈现在我面前。他也知道我知情了。而且，泄密了。他还能对他妻子说什么？我对自己说，这就是终点，绝对的、肯定的终点。
It wasn't the end. Lenny still called 10, 12 times a day. He left messages on my answering machine. "Hello?" His voice filled my bedroom. "Fox, are you there?" Sometimes he didn't say a word. He would stay on the line for as long as five minutes, just breathing.
这不是终点。莱尼仍然一天打10次，12次电话。他在我的答录机上留言。“喂？”他的声音填满了我的卧室。“福克斯，你在那吗？”有时他一言不发。他会在电话线上待上长达五分钟，只是呼吸。
Eventually, he did get to me again. And for the next year that we were together, three days here, four days there, my life became unrecognizable to me. I idly wondered what it would take to get me to leave him. I wondered about this over bottles of chilled white wine or heavy glasses half-filled with scotch.
最终，他确实又让我回心转意了。在接下来的那一年里，我们在一起，待三天，四天，我的生活变得连我自己都不认识了。我无所事事地想，需要付出什么代价才能让我离开他。我看着冰镇的白葡萄酒或半满的烈性苏格兰威士忌酒杯思考着这个问题。
I was still wondering about it when I went to stay for a while at a health spa in California. The phone rang in my room one day. There had been a car crash on a snowy highway. My mother had 80 broken bones. My father was in a coma. They were lying in a hospital 3,000 miles away.
当我去加州的一家健康水疗中心暂住时，我依然在思索着这个问题。有一天，房间里的电话响了。一条雪路发生车祸。母亲有80处骨折。父亲陷入了昏迷。他们躺在3000英里外的一家医院里。
And suddenly, in ways I could not have imagined seconds earlier, nothing else mattered. As I packed my bags, I remembered my mother twirling, dancing to Dvorak, through the doors of Lenny's brownstone, and the glassy look in my father's eyes. I prayed that my father wouldn't die disappointed in me. And I knew then what I had to do.
突然间，以我几秒钟前无法想象的方式，其他一切都不重要了。当我收拾行李时，我想起母亲旋转着、随着德沃夏克的音乐跳舞，穿过莱尼褐石公寓大门的场景，以及父亲眼中那种呆滞的神情。我祈祷父亲不会死在对我失望中。我知道那时我该做什么。
Dani Shapiro, reading an excerpt from he memoir, Slow Motion: A True Story, published by Random House.
丹妮·夏皮罗，朗读其回忆录《慢动作：真实故事》，由兰登书屋出版。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Alix Spiegel and Julie Snyder, contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Jorge Just, Todd Bachmann, and Sylvia Lemus. One of the two engineers who built this studio, I speak to you from today. [? Bill Mayers ?] is retiring this week. My voice comes to you through wires and faders and switches that he soldered into place, one by one, by hand, with his partner in crime, [? Al Mix. ?] He could not have been more generous and helpful and decent to work with. And we're sorry to see him go.
嗯，我们今天的节目由南希·厄普代克和我制作，艾利克斯·斯皮格尔和朱莉·斯奈德共同参与，特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林，以及顾问莎拉·沃威尔。乔治·贾斯特、托德·巴赫曼和西尔维娅·莱姆斯提供了制作帮助。建造这个我今天演讲录音棚的两位工程师之一，[？比尔·梅耶斯？]本周要退休了。我的声音通过他手工焊接的线路、推子和开关，逐一穿过，与他的搭档[？阿尔·米克斯？]一起。在共事过程中，他展现了无比的慷慨、乐于助人和体面。我们很遗憾看到他离开。
If you'd like to buy cassette of this program, or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you know, you can listen to any of our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果您想购买本节目或我们任何节目的磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ，电话312-832-3380。或者您知道，您可以在我们的网站 www.thislife.org 上免费收听我们的任何节目。感谢经营该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。本节目由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[基金资助名录]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who reminds you--
WBEZ管理监制托里·马拉蒂亚，他提醒你——
Jesus Christ heals all those who repent their sins.
耶稣基督治愈所有忏悔罪孽的人。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《这个美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台，PRI。